[Music]
[Larry walks slowly out the front door of a doctor's office, appearing stunned.]
[Siren]
[Newspaper boy:] Extra! Extra! Read all about it! Hiya, Larry.
[Larry continues walking slowly through town and into his office.]
[Music]
[Phil:] Hello, Larry.
What are you doing?
[Larry:] Hello, Phil.
I'm just cleaning out some of this junk.
[Phil:] Are you going someplace?
[Larry:] Yeah, I, uh...
I have to take a couple of days off.
Sort of rest up a bit.
[Phil:] Well, why? What's the trouble?
[Larry:] I just left Dr. Clark, and he says I've got a little lung trouble.
It's nothing serious you understand, it's just a ....
Well there it is, I've got TB!
[Phil:] No! Well, it's a good thing you found out in
time.
What did Clark recommend?
[Larry:] He, umm, wants me to go to bed.
I'm going to stay home for a while and let Mom take
care of me.
[Phil:] Larry, what did Dr. Clark say?
What do you mean?
[Larry:] He wants me to go to a sanatorium.
I'm gonna stay home.That's all there is to it.
[Phil:] No, Larry, there's more to it than that.
We didn't back the campaign to have everyone in Plainville x-rayed
just so that our star reporter could make monkeys out of us.
Look at that story!
How would it look if the man who wrote that story
didn't take his own advice?
Ah, don't be a fool, Larry.
If Dr. Clark thinks you ought to go to a sanatorium, you're going to go.
Even if I have to knock you down and carry you there.
[Larry:] You're not funny, Mr. Baxter.
You're not funny at all.
Now get out of my way!
[Phil:] Larry, Larry. What's the matter with you,
boy?
You can't walk out like this.
Besides, you and Helen are joining us for dinner.
As a matter of fact, Helen is here already.
[Larry:] She is?
Now I've got to tell her.
I'm sorry about blowing off like that, Phil.
I'm all beat up.
[Phil:] I know. It's tough.
You go in and break the news to Helen.
When Carol gets here, we'll come in and rescue
you.
[Helen:] Larry!
Darling, I thought you'd never get here.
But what's the matter, Larry?
[Larry:] I, uh...I've got some bad news, Helen.
You, you better sit down.
[Helen:] Oh now, what happened?
Did Phil fire you?
I hope he did, and then we can get married right away.
[Larry:] No, he didn't fire me exactly...
It's just, I'm just, I'm afraid we can't get married.
[Helen:] Can't get married?
[Larry:] Oh, that is, not right away.
[Helen:] Oh Larry, what is it?
What's wrong?
Have I done anything --
[Larry:] Oh no, no, no, Helen.
It isn't you, it's me.
I've got tuberculosis.
[Helen:] Oh my dear.
Oh, for a moment I thought you didn't love me anymore.
When do you go away?
[Larry:]  Go away?
I don't have to go anywhere.
I'm just going home and go to bed.
[Helen:] Don't you have to go to a sanatorium?
I thought you had to go to one to cure tuberculosis.
[Larry:] You sound as though you wanted me to go.
I thought at least you...
[Helen:] Oh Larry, all I want is for you to get well
just as soon as you can.
[Phil:] [knocks on the door] Hello in there.
Can we come in?
[Helen:] Oh hello, of course you can come in.
Hello, Carol.
[Carol:] Hello, dear.
[Phil:] We'll work this thing out.
Don't you worry, Helen.
[Helen:] You can count on me, Phil.
[Carol:] Hello, Larry.
[Larry:] Hello, Carol.
[Carol:] Phil told me the news, but don't worry.
Everything's going to turn out all right, just as it did
for us.
[Larry:] For you?
[Carol:] Why, didn't Phil tell you?
[Phil:] No Carol, I haven't told them yet.
Sit down.
You see Larry, I had TB myself.
Was cured at the same sanatorium Dr. Clark wants you to enter.
It was pretty tough.
A lot tougher than it should have been, and all  because I didn't think the doctors
knew what they were talking about, wouldn't do what they told me to do.
When I first discovered that I had TB, I was terribly worried.
Carol and I were already married.
It was tough, but my doctor said it was the sanatorium or else.
So I went.
Anyway, I began treatment.
Everything went fine for a while.
Then I began to worry again and got fidgety.
Finally, I just up and left.
Walked out without the doctor's okay.
[Helen:] What happened then?
[Carol:] What usually happens. He had a relapse.
They carried him back to the sanatorium.
[Phil:] And it took that experience to set me wise to myself.
From then on, everything was fine.
Oh, it was slow, but there was progress.
Not just as far as my health was concerned.
There was progress up here, too.
I had time to think and write.
It's because of those stories I wrote in bed that I have this office here today.
I really believe that the three years that I spent in
the sanatorium ....
[Larry:] Three years!
Three years flat on my back in a sanatorium!
No, not me. I want to get married.
You can't expect a girl to wait three years for a
man who ...
[Helen:] Larry, I'll wait for you thirty years if it takes
that long.
Oh you silly darling, I love you.
I, I wish you could go to the sanatorium today
so you could start getting better right away.
[Carol:] And anyway Larry, you didn't get the point.
Phil needed three years because he had a
relapse.
If he hadn't left without the doctor's permission, it wouldn't have happened.
[Larry:] That's fine.
That's just dandy.
It's like you can't wait to get me into that hospital.
Well, it's no good. I can't afford it, I've got a mother
to support.
She couldn't get along without me, she's just ....
[Phil:] Larry, could she get along without you
permanently?
[Larry:] Okay, you win.
[Phil:] No fella, you win.
Well, today's the day.
You'll be at the sanatorium in an hour.
How do you feel?
[Larry:] Okay, I guess.
A little scared.
[Phil:] It's always the first plunge that's bad.
This time tomorrow, you'll be an old hand.
They're a great bunch out there, especially Dr. Martin.
You'll like him.
Let's get going.
[Car door shuts and engine starts.]
[Larry:] It's a nice looking place, Phil, but ....
[Phil:] Wait 'til you see the view from the rooms.
The registration room is right down the corridor.
[Larry:] It's so quiet in here. Where is everybody?
[Phil:] Well, this is the rest period.
Ahhh, here we are.
[Nurse Butler:] Why, Mr. Baxter, we haven't seen  you in a long time.
[Phil:] Nurse Butler, it's nice to see you.
Larry, I want you to meet the gal who saved my life
a dozen times.
All she has to do is smile, and you feel better.
This is Larry Scott.
[Nurse Butler:] How do you do, Mr. Scott.
[Larry:] Hello.
[Phil:] He's my best reporter, I want you to take
good care of him.
[Nurse Butler:] We've been expecting you, Mr.
Scott.
Your records came from Dr. Clark this morning.
Will you check through this form and if all the
information is correct, will you please sign it?
[Phil:] I'm a little worried about our friend.
His mental outlook ....
[Nurse Butler:] We were a little worried about you,
Mr. Baxter.
Remember? Now look at you.
[Phil:] You're right.
He's in good hands.
I think I'll drop in and see Dr. Martin.
[Nurse Butler:] Goodbye, Mr. Baxter.
[Phil:] I'll come up when you're settled, Larry.
[Larry:] See you later, Phil.
[Nurse Butler:] Now if you will come with me, we'll
get you settled in your room.
[Gus:] Come in.
Hi, Nurse Butler.
How's tricks?
[Nurse Butler:] Hello, Gus.
This is Larry Scott, a new patient.
Gus Grazinski.
[Gus:] Hiya, Larry.
[Larry:] Hello.
[Nurse Butler:] You can put your street clothes on
that chair there, Mr. Scott,
and your small things in the night table here.
I'll be back later to see how you're getting on.
[Larry:] Here goes nothing.
[Phil:] All settled, Larry?
Good.
Dr. Martin will be along directly.
How do you feel?
[Larry:] Okay, I guess.
[Phil:] Anything I can do for you?
[Larry:] No, thanks.
[Phil:] Are you sure?
[Larry:] Yeah, I'm sure.
[Phil:] Well, all right.
I, I guess I better be going.
Take it easy, Larry. Do what they tell you to,
and relax, Larry.
Relax.
I'll see you in a couple of weeks.
[Larry:] Bye, Phil.
[Gus:] So your name is Larry Scott.
I knew some Scotts down in Thorndike.
No kin of yours, I suppose?
[Larry:] Nope.
[Gus:] Ever been to Thorndike?
[Larry shakes his head.]
[Gus:] It's a nice town.
I used to be a telephone linemen there.
Ever been to a sanatorium before?
[Larry:] No.
[Gus:] Some guys here been back two and three
times.
They never learn.
Start living high as soon as they get out.
First thing you know, [fingers snap] bang, relapse
and back they come.
Stupid, ain't it?
[Larry:] Yeah.
[Gus:] You're a talkative son of a gun, aren't ya?
You'll get over that.
You'll feel better once you learn how to relax.
[Nurse Butler] Good morning.
It's a beautiful day.
Just try to relax and take a nap before lunch.
[Dr. Martin:] Is anything worrying you, Scott?
[Nurse 1:] Good afternoon, Larry.
Here's that book you wanted.
[Nurse 2:] Good night.
Time for sleep.
[Larry:] Have to rest.
Learn how to rest.
[Phil's voice:] And relax, Larry. Relax.
[Nurses's voice:] Good evening.
Time for supper.
[Phil's voice:] And relax, Larry. Relax.
[Nurse's voice:] Good night. Time for sleep.
And relax, Larry. Relax.
[Larry:] I've got to get out of here.
I'm going crazy.
[Gus:] Whoa.
[Larry:] I gotta get out of here.
[Gus:] Take it easy, Larry. Take it easy.
[Nurse 3:] What's wrong, what's wrong?
You'll wake everyone up by that shouting.
You need to lie down.
[Larry:] Sorry, disturbing....
[Dr. Martin:] Well, Scott, what's bothering you?
Thought we had everything straightened out.
[Larry:] I don't know doctor.
It's, it's just that I can't get any sleep.
I haven't had a good night's sleep since I got here.
Better go home.
I told you I didn't think I could make a go of it.
[Dr. Martin:] If it's your home you're worrying about,
the social worker has told you
that everything is going smoothly there.
[Larry:] Everybody keeps saying relax, relax.
I can't even sleep here.
[Dr. Martin:] You know Larry, relaxation is really a state of mind.
Your state of mind.
Well, I'll see that you sleep tonight.
A light sedative will do the trick.
Tomorrow morning, if you still want to, we'll talk
about your leaving.
Good night, Larry.
[Larry:] Good night.
[Nurse 3:] Good night, Mr. Scott.
[Larry is dreaming.]
[Music plays as if at a carnival.]
[Larry:] What are you doing, Gus?
[Gus:] Shhhhhh, it's a party line.
[Gus laughs]
They're talking about youuuuuu.
[Larry knocks on a door.]
[Larry:] Congratulations!
We're going to be married today.
[Helen:] Oh no, not today.
I said I'd wait thirty years.
[Helen giggles.]
[Paperboy:] Extra! Extra! Read all about it!
Larry Scott is broke. Larry Scott is broke.
[Women on street:] Larry Scott is penniless,
Larry Scott is penniless.
[Operator:] Mr. Larry Scott.
I'm sorry, Mr. Scott isn't in.
He's gone to a funeral.
Whose funeral?
Why, his own funeral, of course.
[Staccato music]
[Policeman:] What's the matter?
You want to die young?
[Paperboy:] Extra! Extra! Read all about it!
[Women on the street:] Larry Scott is penniless.
Larry Scott is penniless.
[Helen:] Wait thirty years.
Wait thirty years. [Laughter]
[Larry:] A dream!
All the fear and terror in that dream.
I feel as if I've been in a fight.
Been fighting all the wrong things.
I've been fighting everything except tuberculosis.
Fighting this bed, the doctors, myself.
I have to stop that.
Have to take a time out.
Learn how to rest.
Have to rest.
Rest.
[Dr. Martin:] Well Larry, how do you feel this
morning?
[Larry:] I feel fine.
[Gus:] You should.
They let you sleep through breakfast.
[Larry:] I'm hungry, too.
I could eat some breakfast.
[Nurse 3:] I'll see if I can find something.
There's some tomato juice on your table.
[Dr. Martin:] Well, your program for the time being
is complete bed rest.
Remember Larry, you're here to rest.
That means conserving your energy in every way
you can.
[Larry:] I'll try.
[Dr. Martin:] Turn over or move around only
enough to keep from getting cramped.
You can sit up to eat or to read occasionally.
[Larry:] Mmmm, good.
[Dr. Martin:] Still want to talk about going home?
[Larry:] No, doctor.
I'm beginning to feel a little better about the whole
thing now.
[Knock on door]
Come in.
[Phil:] Hello, Larry. How are you?
[Larry:] Hello, Phil.
Glad you could make it.
[Phil:] You're looking fine.
[Larry:] Feel fine.
Hey Phil, I want you to meet Gus Grissom, best telephone linesman in Thorndike.
This is my boss, Phil Baxter.
[Gus:] Ex-linesman.
Hi. How are you, Mr. Baxter?
[Phil:] Hello.
What's the matter with him?
[Larry:] Mathematics.
[Phil:] Ohhhh
[Larry:] So tell me Phil, how are Carol and Patrick?
And have you seen Helen lately?
And how's mother?
The social worker tells me she......
[Phil:] Oh wait a minute, one thing at a time.
Your mother is fine.
Helen was over at the house for dinner last night
and...
[Knock at the door]
[Nurse Jones:] Here you are, boys, I brought....
Sorry, I didn't know you had a visitor.
[Larry:] That's all right, Nurse Jones.
This is Mr. Baxter.
Those animals I've been making are for his little
girl.
Of course, they'll be sterilized before Patsy gets
them.
[Nurse Jones:] Hello, Mr. Baxter. I've been hearing about your little girl for some time now.
[Larry:] You think she'll like them, Phil?
Show him that camel, Nurse Jones.
I think that's the best one.
I remember Patsy always liked the camels best at the zoo.
[Dr. Martin:] Well Larry, we can soon let you get out of bed a little each day now.
Your x-rays have been showing steady
improvement, and we can soon...
[Nurse 6:] You're making real progress.
[Larry:] I'll get there.
[Man at desk:] You're up to two hours a day of out-
of-bed activity, Mr. Scott.
Oh, incidentally, the latest issue of the sanatorium
newspaper was really tops.
But, in addition to editing Sidelights, what do you think of a plan to start a class
in short-story writing, with you as instructor?
[Larry:] I like that.
I'd be very glad to do it.
[Nurse Butler:] Goodbye, Mr. Scott.
Take care of yourself.
[Larry:] Goodbye, and thank you for everything.
[Helen:] Larry! Oh, Larry.
[Larry:] Hello, darling.
[Helen:] Oh, I've waited so long for this day.
You about ready?
[Larry:] I have to see Dr. Martin first.
Come on, I want you to meet him.
I'm deeply grateful for all you've done for me, and
well, I hope I can do something for you someday.
[Dr. Martin:] Take care of yourself, Larry.
Remember that you have a new kind of life to live,
and everything will be all right.
See Dr. Clarke.
He's expecting you.
He'll work out a complete set of instructions.
Be sure to follow them.
[Larry:] I'll remember, and I'll do just that.
[Dr. Martin:] Goodbye Larry.
[Larry:] Thanks again for everything.
[Dr. Martin:] Goodbye, Ms. Eisler.
[Helen:] Goodbye, Dr. Martin.
I like that Dr. Martin, Larry.
What did he mean about your having to live a new
kind of life?
[Larry:] Well, a TB patient has to watch himself pretty carefully.
Get enough rest, good food, and dress warmly.
And, of course, see his doctor regularly.
That's what everyone should do, but a TBer has to do it.
[Music]
[Helen writes in her diary.]
[Larry:] "Hi, Larry. Greetings from the new
supervisor of the Thorndike Telephone Company.
I made it! Gus."
Well, good ole Gus Grazinski.
I knew it.
[Typewriter keys clack, then phone rings.]
Hello.
[Dr. Martin:] Larry, I wonder if you could come out
here today and be my prize exhibit.
We have a new patient, a young engineer.
He's a very sick man, and he's tougher to handle than you were.
I thought if he heard your story...
[Larry:] Hold everything doctor, I'm on my way.
[Dr. Martin:] With people like Larry on the team, we
can beat TB.
[Music]